hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about older
language learners
and the reason for that is that um
you know i'm i'm in i'm connected to
these various social networking sites
like uh i don't know uh facebook and
twitter and now google plus and so every
so often you see these things people
that you were following and they're
following you and so there was a message
there from someone saying you know i
want to
do some research on the problems of
older language learners and see what i
can do to help them
so i said what so i posted a little
comment there i said what do you
consider to be an older language learner
and he answered over 40.
so i said what makes you think that
people over 40 have particular problems
in language learning what do you think
these problems might be
and the answer was well you know they
might develop hearing loss or something
of that nature
and i must say i was completely taken
aback by this comment
uh i think that
i don't know that over 40 qualifies as
old
but if i if i
assume that over 60 does that's me
uh i think i'm a better language learner
now than i was when i was 16.
and
all the evidence that i've seen in the
reading that i've done
is that our cognitive abilities don't
really start to decline until
well past the mid 70s
and if we work hard at maintaining these
cognitive abilities by keeping our minds
active
you know i'm sure that they
our cognitive abilities and our ability
to create new neurons and neural
networks remains quite strong
now i can't compare
the ability of us the average 60 year
old with the average
uh 15 year old but everything i've seen
suggests to me that
that obviously a child before the age of
say 10
seems to have a major advantage in
language learning
and there are probably a number of
reasons i think as a very young child of
course the brain
is still flexible enough so that the
brain hasn't sort of formed around
sort of one language so it's much more
open to new languages
as the brain sort of because necessarily
the brain has to form
patterns has to form rules for itself so
that that it can deal with all of the
the experiences and the phenomenon that
it's it's phenomena that it's
confronted with so the the positive side
of this is that as we grow older we have
more patterns in place we have more
experience to draw on we have more
wisdom in a sense we've experienced more
things but we perhaps become less open
to new things
and that's i think what happens on
language learning we're open to any
language when we're born we could learn
any language as a native language and as
we develop therefore this these sets of
patterns to deal with our native
language we perhaps become less open to
new languages and i think their
young people who study two or three
languages have a big advantage but once
we pass the age of 10 or so i think the
brain is more or less formed from what
i've read
and then if i look at young learners the
majority by the way the majority of
teens are not interested in language
learning and don't do well the majority
that i've seen at least in canada
but on the other hand
for example at linc and on the recent
hangouts that i've been conducting in
google plus we've had some young people
show up who are extremely good
and
and i think some of the more
enthusiastic
so-called polyglots people learning
different languages probably are younger
but it's their enthusiasm
and their willingness to put in the time
and the effort and their the fact that
they aren't resisting the language
these are the sort of attitudinal
factors that enable them to be
successful and there's no reason why an
older person can't have the same
attitude i like to feel that when i
study a language i'm totally
enthusiastic about the language i put in
the time necessary i don't resist the
language i don't question
you know why do they say it this way and
wouldn't it be better if they said it
the way we said it in our language
none of these things and i think it may
be true to some extent that um
some people do this but i think young
people do this as well
so
uh
you know i i i
and as for hearing loss like i know i
amongst my friends i don't know of many
of them yeah you do lose the sort of
high frequency range of hearing but not
to the point where it would affect your
ability to hear the language uh now
there are people with hearing aids and
who had developed you know
significant hearing loss i have a very
good friend who's 83 and who has a
hearing aid doesn't hear very well but
he's very enthusiastic learning spanish
and having a great time uh and and so so
i just i felt this like don't ma like
old people aren't in any way
uh disadvantaged older people whether
over 40 as this person had it or over 60
are not handicapped people
and in terms of their cognitive
abilities they're just as good
as younger people
if they have the same attitude if they
have the attitude of not resisting the
language of being caught up in the in
the excitement of learning a new
language
uh not resisting the language if they
can visualize themselves speaking that
other language
if they have these attitudes they can be
just as good as anyone else it is true
that in our society
uh
you know again i was at a meet-up the
other evening here in vancouver it was
styled as a
meetup of language enthusiasts and
linguists
and someone sort of made the statement
well we all know that our ability to
learn language declines with age and as
the older we get the harder it is to
learn and i said no i'm sorry that's not
been my experience well i mean you can't
say that because everybody knows that
the older you get the harder it is to
learn the language
and i think there are a lot of people
who glibly toss these ideas around and
unfortunately i think it influences
some
people who are sort of past their 30s
they think they can't learn a language
anymore nothing could be further from
the truth and
you know it's not just learning
languages you know if i look at my wife
for example who's so enthusiastic about
her piano she plays two three hours a
day she doesn't have a teacher but she's
improving by leaps and bounds
i mean we can learn anything we want at
any age as long as we have the attitude
of a learner the attitude of a learner
is someone who is independent
who doesn't expect someone else to teach
them or to give it to them who's
enthusiastic who's confident and who is
determined
to get there and also someone who isn't
too concerned about comparing themselves
to other people now my wife plays the
piano she doesn't care whether she's
better than someone else i know very
well that there's all kinds of polyglots
on the internet that are better than i
am in a number of languages if not all
that doesn't diminish my enjoyment
one little bit and every one of us as we
learn a language whatever our age and
whatever our opportunities to speak and
so forth
we can all enjoy the progress that we're
making and that's all we need to achieve
is to achieve that little bit of
progress that gives us a sense of
satisfaction we don't have to compare
ourselves to anyone else
um so yeah just to say that
i think there's a bit of a a prejudice
uh and one that's that's that works to
the advantage of of some people who give
up on the op on the possibility that
they could learn one two or more
languages uh you know past their teens
i can assure you that
i mean i learned czech from from
basically a standing start except that i
had done russian within a year i would
never have considered that possible uh
when i was in my 20s you know putting in
an hour an hour and a half or so
eventually two hours a day
and and the reason again it gets back to
you as we're older and as we've done
these things we get better at doing them
we know how to do them again the brain
develops these patterns these these
routines
that
it's no longer a new phenomenon now
someone who has never learned a second
language or has only had say school
exposure to french or
who grew up in china who learned english
for 10 years and can't speak english i
mean they have no sense of what it's
like to transform themselves into a
speaker of a second language so that
they have they have an attitude they're
defeated before they start but that's
the attitude that's not the age and if
they
accept the fact that they can learn that
it's it's a gradual process you have to
do it with enthusiasm and determination
i don't see any difference between a 16
year old and a 66 year old so there's my
take on
language learning and
and older people thank you for listening
bye for now